gotalk rethinking ide accessibility
modern ideas like visual studio have
taken great strides to make their tools
usable by visually impaired people but
they are far from making it an enjoyable
experience due to the linear nature of
information flow between the ide screen
reader and the user a lot of features
are not accessible to screen reader
users that the sighted users take for
granted these features can be grouped
into three categories class ability the
ability of a sighted developer to
quickly glance through tremendous
amounts of code structure and debugging
information this is completely
unavailable to a visually impaired user
get a screen reader limitation debugging
information such as breakpoints are also
not accessible to visually impaired
users navigability the ability to
quickly navigate through code since
visually impaired users cannot glance at
code structure skipping and moving
between functions comments and blocks of
code becomes very cumbersome alert
ability Visual Studio gives the
developer real time error information
through visual cues this is completely
inaccessible to a screen reader user
code talk is a visual studio plugin that
aims to address these issues with code
talk visually impaired developers can
quickly navigate through code get access
to real time error information and debug
with a completely new debugging
experience we call talk points for more
details visit AKA dot ms lash code talk